-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Danny DeVito.
You have some great guest voices
on the show...
-Oh, yeah.
-...including your "Twins"
costar Arnold Schwarzenegger.
-Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Well, you know, when you're --
You know, you're doing the show,
we're doing the --
I asked everybody
that I thought --
when a part came up that
I thought was right for them,
and Arnold immediately said yes,
and that was --
-What was the part
that made you --
-He's an announcer.
-Okay.
-And he's talking about
"the realm of realms!"
And he's, like, got that voice,
you know, that anybody --
You know, you hear that voice,
and it's just like,
"Ah, it's Arnold.
It's Schwarzenegger."
-Did you know him
before "Twins"?
Or did you --
-Uh, no.
-Okay.
-No, I --
The first time I met Arnold,
I was getting out of a car
with my kids in -- at a hotel.
And I was full of all the bags,
you know, the carry-on --
the kids' bags that you have to
have when you've got three kids.
And I was coming out,
and somebody grabbed my arm
as I was getting out of the car
because I was struggling.
And I thought
it was the doorman.
And I say, "Okay, thank you,"
and I got out of the car.
And I turn around, it was --
[as Arnold] "Any time, Danny."
[Normal voice]
And it was Schwarzenegger.
And so that was the first time
I met him.
Then later on, we did -- you
know, then we got to do "Twins."
And then another thing
that happened.
There was a part in the show,
in "Little Demon,"
that was a millipede.
A millipede.
It's like this really weird --
And it was a really great
little part.
So, back up --
Mel Brooks is doing
"History of the World: Part II."
He asked me --
He's executive producer.
He asked me to be in the show
playing Czar Nicholas.
It was four or five lines.
I say, "Yeah, okay, I'll do it."
But in the interest of --
Because I'm from New Jersey --
In the interest of
"I scratch your back,
you scratch my back" --
So Mel Brooks is also
in "Little Demon."
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-A little bit of horse trading
on the side.
-A little bit of horse trading.
-Yeah.
-You know, and Dave Bautista,
who I met -- You know Dave?
-Yeah.
-Amazing guy.
Yeah. You know, it's a lot of --
a lot of great people.
And Rhea had to do it, too.
-Yeah, well, of course.
-Rhea did it.
Yeah, she did, yes.
-You -- We talked about --
We mentioned "Batman Returns."
That's the 30-year anniversary
of that film.
-Oh, boy.
-20 years, "Death to Smoochy."
-Oh, my goodness.
-Do you ever revisit
your old work?
-Oh, oh, I -- once in a while.
You know, every once in a while
I'll catch Oswald because
he's on, you know -- he's
iconically all over the place.
And I love "Death to Smoochy."
So I -- I watch that --
I've watched that
in the past, like, six months.
Six months ago, I watched it.
-And a film you directed,
as well.
-Yes, I did.
Catherine Keener's in it.
-Do you --
Do you love directing?
-I do.
-Yeah, you've done it
a fair amount.
-Yeah, I've done it
a fair amount. Yeah, yeah.
The first one was "Throw Momma."
-Yeah.
-"Throw Momma from the Train."
-Yeah. That was a fantastic
and iconic film.
You got off -- You hit the
ground running as a director.
-Yeah, I love that one.
Yeah, that was a good one.
-You were the perfect person
for a film called
"Throw Momma from the Train."
-Yeah.
-We've talked about this before,
but, you know,
I knew you as a kid.
I grew up watching,
you know, "Taxi" reruns,
and so I knew you from "Taxi."
And then the first time I saw
"Cuckoo's Nest," I realized,
"Oh, my God.
That's Danny DeVito."
-Yeah, that's me.
-That's one of your first, yes?
-That was one of
my first movies, yeah.
-What was your audition like?
What are your memories of --
-Well, "Cuckoo's Nest"
was different
because I was doing the play
off Broadway.
So I was into the character.
So I had months and months
to prepare.
And then I met Milos,
and the rest is history.
I did the play.
I mean, the movie.
And it was, you know, a natural.
I had already done
a lot of the work.
"Taxi," of course --
My famous "Taxi" intro was I --
I was given the script
by a casting director.
This is the way
it usually works.
You get the script, and then
you have to go in and audition.
And I went in with the script.
Nobody knew me.
And all these people
are around the room.
All the writers.
All the producers.
And you've got to audition.
And I said, "One thing
I want to know before we start.
Who wrote this [bleep]?"
And I threw it on the table.
[ Laughter ]
And that was like Louie
walking into their --
-Yeah.
-You know, their -- Yeah.
So that was -- that was that.
And, you know, you audition
for many, many --
-Yeah.
-You know.
-I would assume it was obviously
a little bit different
when you come around
to "It's Always Sunny."
But I -- You can't have imagined
when you started doing that show
that it would be on
for 16 seasons.
-No.
-I mean, what an accomplishment.
-No, but, you know, I saw --
John Landgraf was at FX.
He sent me eight episodes of
this show that had been done
that was "Always Sunny."
The guys did it. Charlie and
Glenn and Rob and Kaitlin.
And I thought it was great.
And then a while went by,
and I just said, you know --
I just gave him my opinion
of the show,
that it was -- I thought
it was a terrific show.
And then like a few months
went by, and they said,
"Would you consider
being on it?"
And I said,
well, if they write a --
you know, a part that was,
like, organic in the show,
that I was, you know,
in a good --
that was funny and all of this.
And then I said, "Well, what --
what part could I play
on that show that would
really be believable?"
And I'm Kaitlin
and Dennis' dad!
It was like
the most ridiculous --
These two tall blond kids.
You know?
And I said, "Well, you know,
how's that going to work?"
And I said, "Well,
the only way it gotta work
is that my wife was a whore."
That's all it is.
And it did work.
You know, kinda, you know --
-Yeah.
-It fit in.
-Yeah, it's very nice.
Very good work
of fixing the script.
-Yeah, you want to get in there,
make sure it's believable.
-Yeah.
When I watch "Always Sunny,"
the thing that I want
more than anything
is authenticity
and believability.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-Yeah.
-You want to be grounded.
-You want to be grounded
when I watch "Sunny."
Hey, it's always a pleasure
to see you.
Congrats on the new show to you,
your daughter, your son.
Danny DeVito.
"Little Demon"
airs Thursdays on FXX
and is available to stream
the next day on Hulu.